well let's talk about heckler how do you
deal with hecklers how do you deal with
whether that's live and in person or
even haters online they you know haters
are out there they're keyboard warriors
sure trigger fingers turn to twitter
fingers striking clips of you uh like
doing crowd work in that way or being
heckled and throwing [ __ ] back so i
always wondered actually if you do a lot
of it i'm not a big uh even if i get
heckled i don't like to post it because
i don't want that to cultivate people to
come out go oh that was a great clip i'm
gonna yell yeah i'm gonna get on a clip
so that worries me a little bit but uh
yeah i get heckled all the time i try to
spin it and try to make it funny the
worst thing you can do with heckle is
just get angry get angry you know if
it's a fat guy like well you're gonna
die soon you're fat [ __ ] then the
crowd's like jesus christ that was grim
yeah so i think it took years but i used
to just be like [ __ ] you you pee
you know all this [ __ ] but now i try to
spin it and make it funny because the
crowd ultimately hates that guy of
course you know so if they're rooting
the show yeah twisted back onto him it
works works every time gotcha that's the
key the and um
you've told some stories about not only
have you been heckled you've been
full-on attacked i have yeah not not on
stage that i know of bro but off stage i
got almost on stage but i've had some
guys step in thank god but uh i almost
got will smith but
uh one time there was a guy in the front
row who was who was heckling me quietly
so no one else could hear but me
so it's just like this gnat in my head
like that joke sucked get up get it get
a better job you stink you know kill
yourself and it's all the thoughts i
have already so he was like validating
them
and i just went off on the guy but no
one else knew he was doing it man so
everybody's like what the hell and they
turned on me so now the whole crowd is
against me and this guy's still heckling
me so i just trashed him and then he got
so mad that he tried to get on stage and
they stopped him but got pretty ugly
yeah trying to win the crowd no no he
was yelling at me you don't understand
it was a sad that's never a good
position to be in no how do you deal
with hecklers amber i had like the
opposite of a heckle but it was still
annoying like i had a guy who knew who
knows all my jokes it comes to all my
shows and he was sitting in the front
row and he was yelling out my punch
lines every time right before i would
get to them but nobody else was really
hearing it except for me and it felt
like i was in an echo and he was the
first one and i was the echo yeah um i'm
not i thankfully haven't been heckled
too much but um because i'm like very
sweet anytime i say something that's a
little bit angry people love it but it's
not my personality
so it has to to be mean yeah it's just
not it's not who i am same it makes me
very uncomfortable
um and i also do you ever watch um new
girl winston how he would prank to the
extreme that's my problem if i go mean i
go like way to me me too there's no in
between i don't know how to be like
smart funny mean all in the same time
and likable with a
so you're bringing a gun to a knife
yeah i hope you get aids
jesus
[Music]